Hi. You a Muslim?
>> Yes, I'm a Muslim.
>> Awesome.
>> Question.
>> Would you trust a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> No, I wouldn't. But can I follow up on
what you were asking the last two guys?
>> Once we get through our line of
question, brother, because we have to
have a main topic and answer.
>> It's the same line of questions.
>> Okay, good. So, we're going to go
through the line of questioning and then
we'll see where we where we end up.
>> So, all right. So, you said no, you
would not trust a religion with
corrupted scripture. Awesome. That's
good. Would you follow a religion that
has non-corrupted scriptures?
>> Yeah, if it doesn't have any corrupted
scripture and it's divinely inspired.
Absolutely, man. Yeah.
>> Okay. Is the correct.
>> So, so just really quick. So, it is the
Torah, Psalms, Gospel, Quran. Are all
these books revealed by Allah? Are all
these books revealed by Allah?
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. Were any of them?
>> As far as far as I know. Yeah.
>> Okay. Were any of them corrupted?
>> Uh, yes. The Psalms, the Torah, the
Gospel have all been corrupted.
>> Okay. And not the Quran.
>> Not the Quran. It's been preserved.
>> Awesome. Okay. So, the Torah, Psalms,
Gospel are Allah's books and they've
been corrupted. Okay. And so, that means
that you follow a religion that has
corrupted scripture. And so, Islam is
not trustworthy.
>> Okay. Sure. So, I'll grant you that same
as the person before did. So, I can ask
you.
>> It's not It's not a grant. Do you I want
to know if you agree with that. Do you
agree that you follow a religion? Yeah.
Do you agree with that?
>> Well, the Quran clarified that all those
sources have been corrupted and is an
appendage to that. So when we follow the
Quran, we're following the fact that we
know those previous sources have been
corrupted and this is the true divine
source.
>> No worries. So you're following a
religion that has a track record of
having corrupted scriptures and then you
just have one good scripture. So you
follow a religion that has corrupted
scripture, right? Well, I just answered
that question.
>> You didn't.
>> I did. I said, "I follow a religion that
has clarified sources."
>> That's not an answer to the question,
you know.
>> Well, then I guess you're right. Uh,
semantically, yes, because those
previous scriptures that were released
by revealed by God were corrupted by man
and they were then clarified.
>> Yeah.
>> There was Yes. previously corrupted
scriptures and we follow the
non-corrupted scriptures.
>> Gotcha. So with that being said,
remember what you said earlier. You said
that you would not follow a religion
that has corrupted scripture. And yet
you admitted that you are following a
religion with corruption.
>> You're right. I changed my answer. I do
follow a script a religion that
previously revealed scriptures that were
non-corrupted and were later corrupted
by man.
>> Got it. So with this admission, you are
following a religion that is
untrustworthy. said that you wouldn't
that you wouldn't even trust a religion
that has corrupted scripture.
>> Yeah. But with that being said, is the
religion untrustworthy or is man
trustworthy?
>> You said the religion you you you
acknowledged that the religion would be
untrust because I said notice what
remember the question would you trust a
religion with corrupted scripture? You
said no. So therefore with you admitting
that you follow a religion that has
corrupted scripture, you are admitting
that you are following an untrustworthy
religion. Islam is untrustworthy.
>> Okay. So can I can I ask you the same
questions
>> after you concede?
>> I I I already said that I did follow the
religion that previously revealed
corrupt.
>> So do you concede that Islam is
untrustworthy?
>> No. Cuz that's not the original
question. The original question was
>> the original question. Yes. The remember
the original question was life. What was
the original question?
>> Would you follow a religion with
corrupted scriptures?
>> And you said,
>> "Yeah, but now you're making the claim
that if man corrupts scriptures, that
makes religion untrustworthy."
>> Well, what we're saying is is that
>> this is crazy. We're we're only going
with what you say.
>> All we did was ask questions. And you to
answer the question just really quick,
>> we notice how we didn't make an
assertion. We only made a conclusion
based off what you said. We asked the
question, would you trust a religion
with corrupted scripture? You said no.
We then asked the Torah, Gospel, Psalms,
Quran, any of those corrupted? You said
yes. The first three.
>> So therefore, now here's the conclusion.
>> Here's the conclusion. This what you
said. So now, therefore, according to
what you just agreed to,
>> Islam is untrustworthy. and yet you
still follow it. So, do you concede that
based on the premises that we laid out
that Islam is untrustworthy?
>> No, I don't. Because that would mean
that I am that would mean that I'm
claiming that because sources were
corrupted by man, that makes our
religion untrustworthy. So, how does how
does man make God untrustworthy?
>> Why did you say you wouldn't trust a
religion with corrupted scripture
earlier? Why did you say no to that to
that question? Why did you say I would
not trust a religion with corrupted
scripture?
>> Yeah, because the source of the
scripture in Islam comes from the Quran
and the Quran is non-corrupted.
>> You didn't ask that's not answering the
question, dude. I'm I'm giving you I'm
being very patient with you.
>> Okay, go.
>> My questions are very simple. They're
very direct.
>> So, we don't have to do this. We don't
got to play. We don't got to do that,
man. It's really cool. Real simple.
>> But does everything have a yes or no
answer?
>> The questions that I asked do. Now, if
you want to expound, you're more than
welcome to allow. You're allowed to
expound. However, you have to answer
first. Yes, no, and expound. Why or why
not? You know, so my question was, why
did you say earlier that you wouldn't
trust a religion with corrupted
scripture?
>> Sure. Cuz a religion with corrupted
scripture is not the word of God.
>> Does Islam have corrupted scripture?
You've already asked me that question.
So, can I ask you the same question?
>> Does does Islam have corrupted
scripture, my friend?
>> Does Islam have corrupted scripture?
Like, is the Quran corrupted?
>> Does Islam, the entire religion have
corrupted scripture? Yes or no?
>> Well, we don't follow the gospel. We
don't follow.
>> I didn't ask what you follow. I asked
you if Islam is no.
>> So, the Torah, Psalms, and Gospel were
not Islamic are not Islamic scriptures.
>> Well, the Quran is an Islamic scripture.
The Torah, the angel. Yes.
Yeah. Well, I mean, yes. The answer is
yes. Without any context. Without any
context, the answer is yes.
>> What do you mean without context? That
it's either yet. It's either yes, the
Torah and Gospel and Psalms are Islamic
scriptures or they aren't. It's simple.
>> I mean,
>> and you can right.
>> Yeah. Can you show me the
>> We can get to that. We can get to that
next. We could get to all that next. So,
the Torah, Gospel, and Psalms are
Islamic scriptures and they're
corrupted.
So you have corrupted scripture in
Islam, correct?
>> I'll answer as a Muslim. Okay. Just
because I mean I want to follow this
keep on going on this conversation. So
I'm going to say yes because following
your train of logic. Yes. That's true.
>> No, not my train of logic. This is
yours. This is yours.
>> No, we're on the same train, brother.
>> Well, you're has to be your position. It
has to be your what you believe. Don't
don't try to be slick because we ain't
going to move on and until you answer
honestly because
>> this isn't our position. This is yours.
>> Yeah. Based on what I said and it's
true. Yeah.
>> Awesome. So based on what you said, you
said that the reason why you wouldn't
trust a religion that has corrupted
scripture is because it wouldn't be from
God. And then there you also
acknowledged that Islam contains
corrupted scripture. So therefore by
your own logic and you said the
conclusion is is that because Islam has
corrupted scripture within it therefore
Islam is not from God. Right?
>> So we're talking about scriptures. We're
saying that God revealed. All right. I'm
answering this question. The answer is
if I I can't just say yes to that
because I'm saying why I'm saying the
psalm, the gospel and the Torah are
correct. The sculpture scriptures,
excuse me. and that the Quran is not a
corrupted scripture. So if I were to say
that anything corrupted does not come
from God, that would mean that the
Bible, the Psalm, and the Torah have
been corrupted and the Quran has not
been corrupted. So the word of God being
the Quran is not corrupted. So Islam is
not an untrustworthy religion because we
follow the Quran.
>> Let me let me let me just ask you the
same question. Is the Torah corrupted?
>> Sorry. Go ahead and ask me again. Yeah.
Has the Torah been corrupt?
>> What is happening, bro?
His his his conclusion
after answering the question and going
taking us in a circle over and over and
over again made no sense. If anybody can
translate and make sense of what he said
at the end of that before he got kicked,
email it to me because and it's only a
Muslim will probably email me because no
one in their right mind would draw the
conclusion he drew while making himself
look like a fool on this stage.
>> Look, my my only message to to the
brother is uh just just go on and go on
and watch your clip back, little bro.
Just go and watch go and watch your clip
back, man. You just go watch a clip
back, you know what I'm saying? And, you
know,
>> see where you messed up, made your
little mistakes.
>> Go and reflect.
>> You know what I'm saying? Come back.
Come new. You know what I'm saying?
>> Go and reflect, man.
>> You let me know if that sounded right.
you got to figure that out on
your own, man. You on your own now,
>> man. I tried I tried my best with you.
>> N99, what's up, man?
>> What's up?
>> How you doing?
>> How good? How are you, man?
>> I'm good. I'm good. Do you uh would you
follow religion with corrupted
scripture?
>> No, that's what you guys are for.
>> Okay. You said no, you wouldn't.
>> No, I wouldn't. That's what you guys are
for.
>> Okay. Uh is the Torah are the Torah,
Psalms, and Gospel Islamic scriptures?
>> They were. Yes.
>> What happened to them?
>> They got corrupted by you guys.
>> So, Islam has corrupted scripture. So,
therefore, it's untrustworthy.
>> No, it's no, the B the Torah, the Bible,
these books are no longer Islamic
scripture.
realize
>> right so so Islam these Islamic
scriptures they used to be Islamic
scripture they now got distorted and are
no longer Islamic scripture so Islam
lost three of its scriptures due to
corruption
>> they lost it the original message is not
lost right that's what I was added on to
>> I didn't ask about the original message
I asked these scriptures that the Quran
sent down
>> it lost these three scriptures due to
corruption is that right
>> yeah the corruption of man they sort of
the
So does Allah have a good track record
of protecting his scriptures?
>> Allah have a good track of uh the
original message is always protected
right. Uh but when it comes to what the
men have changed what man has changed.
>> So do we do we do we have the do we have
the original message of the do we have
the original meh original message of the
Torah and gospel in Psalms today?
>> In the Psalms the original message if
you want to say the original message is
to worship one God. Sure. Yeah. That's
the original message. But uh the the
actual message of God,
>> do we do we do we have it today? Do we
have the original message of the Torah,
Psalms, and Gospel?
>> The original message. What do you mean
by that? Like
>> what you've been saying this entire time
we've been talking.
>> Yeah, the original message of worshiping
one God. The Torah does preach that,
right? And that's the original message.
Uh you guys have messed up.
>> Is that all?
>> Yeah. Things like, oh, the um worship
one god, don't steal, don't harm your
neighbor. These things, these are
Islamic beliefs, right? But we don't
believe in
>> Are these the original messages?
>> Are these the original messages? Yeah,
sure.
>> Okay. So, do we have the original? Do we
still have the original message of the
Torah, Gospel, and Psalms?
>> In the books itself, there are some
parts where it's still the original
message. Yes.
>> And there's other parts that are
corrupted.
>> Majority of the book is corrupted. Yes.
>> Got it. So, majority of your Islamic
scriptures got corrupted. Is that right?
>> It's no longer Islamic scriptures,
right? If someone goes,
>> is the is the Torah a Christian a
Christian book or an Islamic book? The
Torah, you guys have made it into a
Christian book.
>> I'll ask it again. Is the Torah a
Christian book or an Islamic book?
>> The original Torah.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. The original Torah is Islamic
book, but not this version. No.
>> The Psalms. Is that a Christian book or
an Islamic book?
>> The original book. Yes.
>> The Gospel. Is that an Islamic book or a
Christian book?
>> The original. Yes.
>> So, all of these books are Islamic
scriptures. Correct.
>> Yes. The original. Sure. And these
original Islamic scriptures got
corrupted. Correct.
>> The original ones got corrupted by man
to make space for the Quran to come and
be. Got it. So, so, so basically it was
Allah's will for these scriptures to be
corrupted to make space for the Quran.
>> No, we as humans have free will and
humans like you guys corrupted the
books.
>> Brother, why did you why did you why did
you just say no to what you just said? I
repeated you word for word what you just
said and then you said no to it. Did you
are you are you aware of that?
>> What did you say?
>> No. No. No. You should be asking what
did you say? You didn't you don't
remember what you said.
>> I I said the Quran came as the final
message. So now you said other books.
>> That's not what you said. Are you
>> That's not what you said. Re That's not
what you said. Did you not Did you not
say that the previous scriptures were
corrupted to make space for the Quran as
the final revelation? Did you is that
not what you said?
>> The book corrupted so down.
>> Is that what you said?
>> Yeah, I said the original message got
corrupted, right? But but the original
books got corrupted so God sent Quran.
>> Wow. This is insanity, bro.
>> Go ahead and watch your watch your clip
back. Man,
>> this is crazy, bro.
>> This is Islam, man. Y'all hear this?
Allah willed for the previous scriptures
to be corrupted to make space for the
Quran. Because if the Torah, Psalms, and
Gospel were preserved and authoritative,
there would be no need for the Quran. So
Allah said, "You know what I'mma do?
I'mma send these scriptures, but I'm
going to have them be corrupted so that
there's room for the Quran to come."
>> Mhm.
>> So trustworthy. Very trustworthy. So
trustworthy.
>> To make space. Hey G. A. Ain't that the
truth, man?
>> Ain't that the Zus?
Uh,
>> hey, what's going on?
>> What's up, Tubby? Are you a Muslim?
>> No, I accidentally requested it. I'm
about to leave this anyways, but um
>> Okay.
>> I just want to say I appreciate what you
do and I love your videos and uh yeah,
keep defending Christianity. I got to go
though.
>> God bless you, Toby.
>> All right.
>> Thank you for that, man. All right,
guys. Muslims, come on up and request.
Come on up and request and and and and I
mean, come on, guys. Y'all got to y got
to do better than this. Y'all got to do
better than this, man.
>> Um let me get to some super chat, man.
This is
>> this is But hey, this is what this topic
do to them, bro.
>> You get you get you get some of the most
confusing answers and you just let them
talk. You just be like, "Do you hear
yourself?" And apparently they don't cuz
they don't even they can't even repeat
what they said 10 seconds ago.
>> Matthew Smith says, "Why would Allah not
protect a sinless man's scripture?"
Yeah, just let the Messiah scripture get
corrupted. Incredible. Says, "Yeah, have
you ever heard Have you ever read a top
seer that genuinely gave you more
understanding than what was right in
front of you in the verse? Are Muslims
illiterate?" It be like that, man. I'm
not going to lie. There'll be some
verses where the top seer has helped me
out, but uh for the most part, you don't
need them. But there are some parts
where their commentary or their
explanation has brought some light to
some things for sure. LA Apologetics
with this $100 super chat. Thank you so
much, bro. He says, "Avery and life, you
two together is straight gold. Thank you
both for glorifying our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ. God bless you both. Jesus
is king." Amen to that, man. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> God bless you, LA. Appreciate it.
Josevita says, "Hey all, please pray my
for my husband Farooq
uh shake to take Jesus as his Lord and
Savior and be united to his wife and his
child and uh lead us to Christ." Amen.
Yeah. We pray for your husband that he
comes to the truth of the Lord. That's
all of our prayers. And Jameus said
Jameson says he can he just conceded if
corruption doesn't mean the religion is
not trustworthy. What's his problem with
Christian with what's his problem?
What's his problem with Christianity in
his worldview? Then did anyone else
catch that? Yeah. He he justified having
corrupted scripture in your religion. Uh
this is an earlier guest earlier earlier
guest. He justified uh Islam having
corrupted scripture and it being okay.
So then there should be no problem with
Christianity if he thinks that we have
corrupted scripture.
>> And I I'm glad that he caught that
because sometimes I drive them to that
same conclusion where as if they admit
this right and then they they do exactly
what you just caught. I said the same
thing. I'm like, "Well, then you you
really have no issue with Christianity
because of what you guys do the entire
time." Like the like before this
argument they would Christianity is
untrustworthy. Why? Cuz your scriptures
are they they still do it today when
you're not running it. Your scriptures
are corrupted. Your scriptures are
changed. But then we literally see they
are the ones that are openly admitting
that their scriptures are corrupted and
changed. But yet their religion gets to
remain true.
>> Oh yeah.
>> You can't make this stuff up with
Muslims, bro. They hear and do the exact
opposite of what they what they think.
Bro, it's it's it's honestly
mindboggling, bro.
>> Yeah. Z says, "Welcome to the masid.
Leave your slippers and your brains at
the door before entering the house of
Islamic Islamic Allah."
>> Oh my gosh, bro.
>> Aaron Wild says, "Muslims study yapology
and speak Yapanese. They always fail
yapology because they can't stay on
topic when writing papers and answering
questions. When writing papers, they
always start with we believe and in the
end and they end it with is Jesus gut.
That's too good. We got rid who says,
"Love your work, man. Thank you for
staying consistent. God is doing great
things with your ministry online and
apologetics." Thank you so much, bro. I
appreciate the support, man. Thank you.
Thank you. Uh we got Tai the Fly Guy
says, "How would Muhammad know those
stories? he can just hear them and have
them in his memory. I still remember
Goldilocks story and I couldn't read
back then. These Muslims really downplay
Muhammad's intelligence without knowing.
And God bless from Matt. Thank you so
much. Uh LH says, "Sai Muslim 165B.
Muhammad called Moses the son of Imran,
which means that he would be Mary's
brother." Tough. We got another big
super chat. Wow. from Ver Dolarum says,
"Happy belated birthday, Avery. It is
still my birthday month, so I guess this
works."
Uh, thank you so much. He says, "Do
Muslims know that the book of James was
written in 45 AD and preserved until
today?" Uh, yeah, but that that
preservation is probably corrupted. No
Days Off podcast says, "Did your wife
finish reading her Quran verses?" But
but for real, God bless you guys. Been
trying to find your email. Can't get a
hold of you. I would love to get you on
our podcast. Yeah, the email is uh
attached to the in the description of
every video. So, it's in the description
of this video and so yeah, the link is
there.
>> Omar, how you doing? Hello.
>> Yeah. What's up, man?
>> What's up, man? My friend Life has a
question for you, bro.
>> Yeah.
>> What's up, Omar? You all right, man?
>> All right. So, you know, would you
believe in a religion with corrupt
descripture?
>> That's kind of a dumb question.
>> Well, can you answer the dumb question?
Would I follow a religion with? Well,
let me explain why the scripture was
corrupted. So, previous Why are you
laughing?
>> Answer the question before you just
start explaining. Bro, what? What? What
are you explaining? You answering a
question I didn't ask you.
>> Okay, then. Yes, I would.
>> Oh, you would follow a religion with cor
with with corrupted scripture
>> with previous corrupted scripture which
was then corrected and revealed.
>> But that that's fine. We can deal with
that in a minute. So, you do follow a
religion with corrupted scripture.
previously corrupted scripture and then
new scripture was revealed that
corrected it. Yes.
>> Yes. Let me hear you say I am a Muslim
and I follow a religion with corrupted
scripture.
>> Previously
was corrupted.
>> So So the answer is yes. You Omar follow
a religion with corrupted scripture. The
religion of Islam contains corrupted
scripture.
>> I mean no it doesn't currently contain
cor uh the scripture because it's not
part of Islam anymore.
>> What happened? And it just it just got
uncorrupted or what? It was corrupted.
Disappear. It was corrupted. After it
was corrupted, it's no longer part of
the sin.
>> Well, if it didn't well, if it didn't
get fixed, right? If the scriptures
didn't get fixed, if it was fixed, they
revealed a
>> So, where's the uncorrupted inje?
>> Huh?
>> Where's the uncorrupted inje got fixed?
>> What do you mean? It was the Quran came
and corrected your corrupted version.
>> Is the angel still corrupted today?
>> The current book that's in Torah.
Yes.
>> So you still have corrupted scripture in
your religion.
>> It's no longer a part of our religion.
>> It is part of your religion. It's just
corrupted. You have corrupted part of
your religion.
>> It's been corrupted. It's no longer part
of their religion. The way if somebody's
belief is corrupted how it works take
them out of the fold of how it works.
Yes, it is how it works.
>> All right, cool. Find me Muhammad in the
>> Why does Muhammad need to be in the
>> Cuz your Quran says he is.
>> What?
uh give proof.
>> Chapter 7 verse 157.
>> Can you read it out?
>> Those who follow the unlettered prophet
whom they find written with them in the
Torah and the Injil.
>> Look at that. Recited it too, man. They
recited.
>> Well, I know uh what's it called? Islam.
I don't know if you've heard of him.
He's written reputations on that. I just
don't have it currently listed. And I
>> refuted the Quran. Listen, if you guys
were gen No, he refuted that claim that
Chris has made because all your guys'
>> ref
You jumping all over the I don't even
know what your What you are you Now
you're trying to make me seem uh stupid.
>> Where is Muhammad in the NGO?
>> I just told you if you were genuine if
you were genuine trying to find
>> Where is Muhammad in the
>> Can you let me finish?
>> Omar.
>> Omar,
>> can I finish?
>> Where is Muhammad? You see how deceptive
you got to be in order to
>> You guys, you guys,
>> you can't answer a simple You can't
answer a simple question. You said the
audience.
>> Can I just answer? Can I
>> Please, please forgive my co-host.
Please forgive him. His his heart is
deviated, brother. You got to forgive
forgive the host. All right.
>> Can I just answer you've sat in the
audience tried to figure out the best
way to deviate from the conversation as
best as you can.
>> I'm not trying to devate from the
conversation. You know, you as a Muslim
know for a fact you would not go on your
masid and say the religion of Islam
contains corrupted scripture.
>> It doesn't contain corrupted scripture
because it's no longer
>> You just said it did.
>> No, it No, I didn't. What are you?
>> So, do you follow Okay. So, do you Okay,
so now be honest here. Let's deal with
it. That's why you're opting out of
answering the question.
>> I'm trying to answer the question.
You're not listening. Where can Look,
you said it's not part of You said the
Injil isn't part of your religion
anymore. So you guys don't have the
angel anymore.
>> No.
>> Okay. So where can we find Muhammad in
the jail?
>> Can I answer? Can you without you
interrupting? Give me like 5 seconds to
speak. Okay. Obviously I don't have the
verse, but I I know for a fact that if
you took two seconds to research one of
my scholars giving a verse where
Muhammad is mentioned, it's there. All
the proof is there. The truth is there
for those who seek It's where it's
where. Mention where?
>> I I literally I would just I'll take
like a two second research and find it.
>> No, like like No, no. What I mean like
you don't have to give me the exact like
verse per se, but where what what is the
source? Are you going to be going in the
Quran? Where are you going to be going?
>> Wait. Also, wait. Uh where does it say
in the Quran that
>> Jesus is my Lord and Savior? No.
>> 757.
>> 7. Can you uh say the verse one more
time?
>> Chapter 7, bro. Chapter 7 verse 157.
Please stop stalling.
>> Where are you where are you saying that
your scholar went to
>> to to say that Muhammad's in in the in
the NGO? What where what was his source?
Where was he going?
>> I'm trying to pull it up right now, but
my computer's loading.
>> I I you don't How do you not understand?
>> I I don't have it memorized. No, I don't
have
>> I'm not asking you to give me the exact
verse. What is the source that he's
going to
>> the Torah?
>> So, we still have the Torah today?
>> No.
So then why would your scholar be still
go be going to the Torah if we don't
have it? If he didn't have it, how is he
going to the Torah?
>> And he said,
>> why does he need why does that need to
>> Huh?
>> You don't have it and it's not part of
your religion anymore. So where are they
going to? It shouldn't be nothing they
should go they can go to.
>> It doesn't need to be a part of their
religion to go to it for a one certain
topic.
>> What? Hold on. I'm confused. I
>> the the Torah you're saying was
corrupted and is therefore no longer
part of the religion. Yet your scholars
are still going to the Torah to find
Muhammad mentioned in there like their
Quran says he would that they can. So
that means that the Torah they're going
to is part of the religion still that
contains Allah's revelation, right?
>> Give me the Wait, can you give me the
verse again? The
>> I'll give you the verse.
>> Chapter 7. What?
>> Go ahead. Take that verse. There's the
verse. Go find it. Go find the verse.
>> Oh my goodness. freaking stage, man.
>> The Torah in the NGO is no longer a part
of the Islamic religion because it's
corrupted. So, they threw it away, said
it's no longer theirs. And there, that's
how you clear it up. Anything that
exists that makes Islam look
untrustworthy, we just remove it and say
it's not ours anymore. We just disown
it. So therefore, so therefore, Islam
becomes true again.
>> Good grief. Are like guys, for the
Muslims that are going to come up
I want you guys to know, you are
embarrassing yourselves. You're
embarrassing Islam. Rightfully so.
They're like, "This is what Islam does
to you." But I'm just saying, we don't
we're not doing it. We're not making fun
of you. We're not trapping you. This is
what you're doing to yourselves. Okay?
So, for the next guys come up, just
tread lightly. Be careful. Think, you
know what? I represent my God. I
represent the prophets. I represent my
parents, my wife and my children, my
husband. Whatever it is, I represent
these people. So, I'm not gonna come up
here and embarrass myself and them. All
right. We have a Muslim here on stage.
>> Yeah. That's bad. Muslim.
>> Yes, sir. How's it going?
>> Pretty good.
>> Would you believe in a religion with
corrupt description?
>> Of course not.
>> All right. Cool. So, how many sets of
scriptures were revealed in your
religion?
>> Uh, so the preserved scripture that we
have is the glorious Quran. How many
sets of scriptures were we building in
your religion?
>> Yeah, I'm going to respond. So, we do
believe in prior scriptures, but in the
same way you also believe that Noah had
scriptures that Abraham had the scroll.
>> I'm not asking you the scrolls, but
Abraham, right? So, are those those are
lost and corrupted? If you have any
fragments of that,
>> I'm going to count how many. Oh, he
answered it.
>> Yeah. Well, no. No. I just I just pulled
it out. Now, I got to see if he lost. He
>> said I pulled it out. cuz you can't you
can't get him to answer nothing straight
cuz listen brother if you say if you say
that we have to have
>> he really didn't answer it but
>> if I if I can just have two minutes to
talk
>> no if you say it's a condition
>> if you say it's a condition
>> so you two minutes already
>> so we're going to pause here bro so look
I'm just going to tell you how this is
going to go man this isn't no two-minute
monologue time this isn't no that's not
how we're doing this we're going to have
normal human conversation where there's
a back and forth where there's
engagement with questions asked. Okay?
So, please engage as a human being, not
as a robot that has a programmed script
and let's talk about it. All right. How
many of your scriptures, how many of the
scriptures that Allah revealed got
corrupted? If you can answer that,
please.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, today the only uncorrupted
scripture is the Quran. So how many
>> So how many scriptures of Allah got
corrupted?
>> You got to subtract and get your number
from out of there.
>> Allah revealed the Torah.
>> He revealed the Zab thems
and the Quran to the prophet Muhammad.
The of Abraham and so on.
>> Allah revealed four books and three of
them got corrupted.
How many authentic books are left,
Johnny? The only authentic book left is
the Quran.
>> So if there's only one book that's left
authentic, Johnny, then how many books
got corrupted?
>> So what's what's your point?
>> How many books got corrupted?
>> Cuz are you saying if Revelation,
>> how many books got corrupted
authentic? If you're saying that past uh
past books being corrupted is an issue,
well that's first of all a problem for
you. And number two,
>> go ahead and finish that. Go ahead and
finish that in. Watch your head, man.
>> What is happening, dog?
This question, do people I haven't ran
this in so long outside of two days ago.
Bro, this is what is happening, bro.
What's uh what's what's three? What's uh
I don't even know anymore, bro.
>> What's
four minus one, man? Three. I can't even
I can't even do math no more because
they ain't answering the questions. Now
I'm I'm I'm starting to soak in soak up
day. Like I'm starting to think like
them, bro.
>> Let's do this. Let's do this. Uh
>> oh man. Let's get Let's get Let's get
Shamzu up here. Let's uh Yeah, let's do
you.
>> This was four minus three. Good. Can't
even think no more,